[Music]  waimakiri is one of new zealand's  fastest growing districts so we need to  ensure our growth is well planned and  sustainable the district plan is a  framework that will help us cater for  our growing population  while also ensuring our natural  resources rural character and cultural  aspects are cared for and preserved  it sets out rules for how the district's  land can be used developed and  subdivided  and determines what activities need a  resource consent  the council have reviewed our current or  operative district plan now we're  seeking feedback on the proposed  district plan  to view the plan and learn more about  the proposed changes jump online to  waimakariri dot govt dot nz forward  slash let's talk  you